mouth watering smokey pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now
this is incredible there's the shoulder
yeah and look
there's the shoulder blade if you go
through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called
a butt the slower you cook it the more
juicy it is
and it's great for big parties because
you just come along and get your fork
and shred it a delicious
smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay i'm gonna
leave the roots on
okay because i want this to sit
underneath the port
it gives it a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now
i'll peel the garlic okay i'd like you
to crush the garlic we're gonna make a
really nice little paste okay
go on maggie come on come on come on
nice good girl one more crush
come on maggie i'm coming sorry about
that
little cup there now this
is a beauty paprika smoked paprika
i love it so three nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons
of brown sugar salt please
and pepper could go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now olive oil
in
mix that some thyme in there so we got a
sort of fragrant
rub time stalks underneath
so that's even more flavor going on on
the bottom pour that
all over it now this is where you gotta
be really quick
okay and sort of rub that mashed sausage
in almost
exactly that smells amazing
honestly you just drizzle a little touch
of olive on top of that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinading of the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if i was
doing this for a sunday
and start marinating thursday friday so
it gets even tastier
right quite easy as well to make it's
very easy five and a half to six hours
in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are going to pimp some shot-bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you have to twist
to us
yeah there's so many things something
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness
but there's some heat coming okay and
i've got a little bit
of you know this chipotle smoked
chipotle paste
i love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah you can
use it for any sandwiches really any
sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
i've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's our nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready
just time to knock up a couple of tried
and tested party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water
skins and all meanwhile finely dice
sweet pickled gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty gruyere cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush
and add your spring onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling
of grated greer these simple
cheesy crushed potatoes are equally
delicious served hot
or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make a really nice
fresh broccoli salad now these are
called florets
and that's the best part of the broccoli
okay the bit that everybody wants
once they're off i'm gonna slice the
broccoli
okay mm-hmm never had raw broccoli
before it's always been cooked
really when you dress this with the
dressing it's incredible
now a little season early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in
a teaspoon of sugar please daddy little
smell
cider vinegar mmm there you go
finely chopped shallot in with the
broccoli
so delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
currants i love them that gives that
nice sort of chewy texture
all right lift up your bowl please nice
and gently half of that
in the middle please thank you and stop
and then mix that up with me
okay a little taste
so good and it's kind of salad that
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow for
this look at this
megan honestly that is amazing
it's beautiful that is incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that i
thought we would have a tiny bit
just before we go to the table just a
little bit
honestly meg don't tell mom
thank you honestly do i do it i'm gonna
do it
that is incredible so good you promised
me
you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go come on
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cook smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple sides of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw
deliciously yummy dishes that will have
your family friends
and work buddies coming back for more
right how's the ball
a great stick to your ribs stew here's
my favorite
beef and ale with mustard dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest tilly
tilly first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour nice
yeah good girl what's the flower going
to do dad
the flower helps to brown the beef a
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor
and thicken the stew i feel a bit like
marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
look at the size of the chunks of the
beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally be
similar
similar size that's right does that mean
they'll cook equally that's right
now these are little pearl onions i'm
going to put them in hole as well
everything has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
oh matilda she promised you weren't
going to mention that
what was that time
time and what are they bay leaves
bailey's good girl
a tablespoon of oil in the beef goes in
first
okay in
a really nice color got a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in good go
garlic pearl onions in
good give that a really good mix up
stews are very easy to make providing at
the beginning
you give it a little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned um is
beer
and that's going to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout
helps to tenderize the beef and give it
a hearty delicious flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew yeah
i'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please because it's so
nice
and there's one final thing in there
cover the steering steak
with the beef stock give that a little
mix with daddy please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you
serve it oh yes is the garlic going to
be burnt
no excuse me right and we always put the
lid
with a little bit just a little bit so
it can breathe that's right
not make the stew all watery into the
oven at 150 please tails for about two
and a half hours
and now you can focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one
twice baked bubble and sweet jacket
potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside
and cook through in the middle slice
them in half
and scoop out the soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter
mix in the cabbage and season to taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes
or until the tops are nice and crispy
and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah beef juice
chewing stewing
let's get on with our delicious hearty
pet art i've been looking forward to
this
you and i chef i'm gonna prep the pears
so if you peel
i'll top and tail into quarters pears go
soft in the oven very very quickly
so we're gonna put them on a tart you'll
need to leave them whole half or in
quarter
what's that in there ginger that's right
a stem ginger so you stem ginger and
fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup
good girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go
so it's a bit of a um different one to
grate this
because it doesn't really come through
like the cheese
no i'm gonna make that little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it so easy to
do
so give me your finger that's my center
point i want you to get
the pears going around like that in a
really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
we've egg washed the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue
that's right crimple this with our
finger
and the paste reforms this nice little
shelf like a little money bag
are you going to do anything with the
spare pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
we've got the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger let me go around mike
with your we might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar
so that caramelizes it and colors the
pears beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glaze is the pastry so the pastry has
this really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top and then
put that there 180
and in she goes you smell the beef
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that
i want you to just i was hoping you'd
ask
just have a little taste
how's that taste now i'm not allowed
anymore
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour
for a fluffy result but if you like your
dumplings hard
use plain flour next the dumpling
essential
suet that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
thank you followed by a generous dollop
of grain mustard
two fingers start rolling the fingers
round
and i've got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now
a nice little whisk your fingers are
getting tired right now put your hand in
there now it should bring
all that dough together i'll show you
the best way to get that nice and clean
sprinkle the flour on your hands rub
them together
all that will come off nice that's a
good way
isn't it now we've got this wonderful
dumpling mixture how squidgy is that
a little flour on your hands okay roll
these
lengthways and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand off we go
smell that mustard in there huh
come on you never trust you with
something like that
yes please silly
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock 12 in the center and put
that back into the oven
for 20 minutes to cook the dumplings now
if you open the door for daddy i'm going
to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please nice and gently all the way
around
good girl little taps the others are
gonna love this it looks a bit like a
snowy cake
doesn't it good job now very carefully
carry that to the table how
nice does that look delicious okay i'll
check on the dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely a final sprinkle of
chopped parsley and our stew is ready
for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we don't have to be
sure
we have to be very sure
[Music]
um that is an amazing
hearty beef stew with dumplings right
the twice baked loaded potatoes
and we are ready this
is my ultimate hearty dinner a
comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings
and twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied
a rich and zingy pear and ginger galette
let's go holly are you ready for some
delicious
beef stew yeah oh wow thank you very
much
delicious thank you
we'll be able to heat this up for mom
and jack when they come back
easy even two or three days later tasty